what can you do and what will be
addressed at these meetings on the on
western Africa and for that matter in
dallas texas with Ebola well I'm really
pleased that you mentioned that but the
IMF does its bit too and in the most
expedited time with collective drive
from both the staff and the board of the
IMF we approved last week a package off
130 million u.s. dollars to go to these
three countries so people don't notice
about you they don't know agree annual
you get at the IMF let's go right to
Liberia okay i did a deeply emotional
interview the other day and surveillance
with a woman from liberia who literally
talked about how people are dying what
will the IMF do to assist liberia we
cannot cure people we cannot finance
hospitals we cannot send doctors which
is what is most needed but it's for
others to do that and i'm delighted that
the World Bank is is doing its fair bit
as well we are in the business of
providing financial support to states in
needs and what we do is that we give
budgetary support on in the case of
Liberia they need money because they are
not collecting tax or for obvious
reasons they have additional expenses
for obvious reasons so in a very
expedited way we said okay bingo we're
going to put together an additional I
forgot whether it was 40 or 45 million
dollars for Liberia so that you can
immediately you know go about spending
public money in order to improve the
treatment in order to get the doctors to
come in in order to buy the equipment to
isolate people that that's what the IMF
can do that's our mission to provide
financial support to countries that are
facing difficulties of that nature